good morning hank it's tuesday may 18th
which means the anthropocene reviewed
book is
out today i have to do a tv thing i am
somewhat nervous about but first a while
back i discussed the strange joy of
having my books go to places
i will never go like starting today the
book has a life separate from its author
and it gets to go on all kinds of
adventures around the world
forging whatever connections it can with
whomever reads it anyway in response to
my talking about that nerdfighters jim
and rhett made the
anthropocenereview.com a domain name i
am now very grateful i never bought and
built a website where people can share
the approximate location of their books
and also review that location it has
been such a joy to see the book start to
travel this morning and to read your
wonderful reviews of your locations so
if you have a moment go to the
anthropocenereview.com
and let people know where your book
ended up also share a picture of your
signature if you got an autographed one
i'm very interested to know where all
the signatures went okay i gotta go do
this tv thing cut to me looking nervous
here we are i'm getting my makeup done
hank um this is my favorite thing i
it just it feels like a nice person is
putting a protective shield on me that's
how i always feel when i'm getting my
makeup done
and i'm ready there's also a discord
channel where you can discuss the book
with other people in the community link
in the doobly-doo
also reviews are coming in and so far
they are very nice like the san
francisco chronicle said i want to make
sure i quote this correctly the
anthropocene reviewed is the perfect
book to read over lunch or to keep on
your nightstand for whenever you need a
reminder of what it is to feel small
and human in the best possible way by
the way that review also says green
is a ravenous and tender polymath which
is very kind even though
i feel like proper polymaths know how to
say that word and i've never been
totally confident about my pronunciation
of it okay now i really have to go do
this tv thing
here's a picture of drew barrymore
hugging my book after she said she loved
it so
that was nice i'm back i hope that tv
thing went okay but the most important
thing is that it's over and i
am where i belong in my basement also
another great review just came in i hope
you don't mind if i read a little bit of
it it made me really happy
lyrical and beautiful funny and hopeful
intricate and entertaining all at once
green may have made his name by writing
fiction and for good reason but this
first foray into non-fiction is his most
mature
compelling and beautifully written book
yet what else the virtual tour started
last night with the brilliant clint
smith and it was so fun that for a
little while i forgot i was even on
zoom the tour rolls on tonight with
special guests radio lab co-host latif
nasser and sarah yaristgreen and then on
wednesday with hank and sarah and then
on saturday with ashley c ford and sarah
it's going to be a lot of fun tickets in
the doobly-doo
it's been a long three years and a
really really long year and a half
and i'm just so grateful that the book
is here
i wrote the book because i wanted to
write my way back to wonder
and hope and sustained attention and it
gave me that gift
and i hope it can give you something of
that gift too
last thing for me and it may not be easy
for me to say but
hank this book started with you it
started with big
sprawling conversations about our human
moment and how to make sense of it and
it started with belly laughs
on a tour bus during a cross-country
road trip like so much of my work and
life
it starts with you there's a
long-standing inside joke around here
that the protagonists of all my novels
are only children because i don't like
to write about siblings but
that's not true uh the truth is
that writing about siblings is is too
close to my my vulnerable and beating
heart
this book finally does have a main
character with a sibling and you are at
the beginning in the middle and the end
of it
telling me what i need to hear with wit
and empathy
and love just like in real life i loved
writing about you almost as much as i
love
and miss being able to hang out with you
so
thank you thank you for inspiring this
book and for supporting me
every step of the way thank you thank
you
thank you hank i'll see you on friday